Bitte schön.
Guten Tag, ich heiße Bishakaradak.
Ich bin die Physiosteinige Ersten.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Bevor wir über Ihre Bischewarden sprechen, würde ich Ihre persönliche Daten erfrägen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Paul Fischer.
Paul Fischer.
Kann ich Ihre Vorunnachnahme langsam ausprobieren, bitte?
Vorname ist Paul.
Pauler Anton.
Ulrich Ludwig.
Nachname Fischer.
Friedrich Ida.
Siefried Caesar.
Heinrich Emilrich.
Danke schön.
Wie heißen Sie, Herr Fischer?
Ich bin 49 Jahre alt.
Ich bin abends 15.975 geboren.
195.
Danke.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß.
Und wiegeln Sie?
92 kg.
90 kg.
Danke.
Was sind Sie vorhin beruflich?
Ich bin Taxifahrer.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich war verheiratet.
Ich bin geschieden.
Ach so, ja.
Und wollen Sie jetzt allein oder mit anderen Leuten ein?
Nein, ich lebe allein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben mit meiner ehemaligen Frau einen gemeinsamen Sohn.
Sind Sie gesund?
Er ist gesund, ja.
Okay.
Was für sich Sie zu uns?
Unser Erfolg ist, ich hatte ein Freund beim Umzug geholfen.
Am folgetag habe ich dann Schmerzen in meinem Nackenbereich gehabt.
Die bis in meinen rechten Schulterblatt ausstrahlt.
Und die Schmerzen seit einer Woche gehen nicht weg.
Ich habe starke Schmerzen.
Ich habe nicht ganz beschrieben, wie die meisten sind.
Du fadig pulsieren, zählen, stehlen, polen.
Die ziehen der Schmerz.
Und Sie haben mir schon gesagt, bis Schulter ausgestanden.
Ja, ich traf mich sogar auf die Seite.
Ist das einseitig oder beides?
Rechts.
Seit heute Morgen, glaube ich, richtig?
Nein, seit einer Woche.
Seit einer Woche, danke.
Nach dem Umzug, das war vor einer Woche, habe ich die Schmerzen.
Und die Schmerzen sind, haben sich nicht verändert.
Die sind die ganze Zeit schlimm.
Ich nehme Medikament ein, aber es hilft mir nicht.
Überproofen oder irgendwas?
Ja, ich habe nur Valgin zu Hause.
Erinnert es sich, wie viel Milligramm?
Dosierung?
Ja, das ist eine Tablette, die hat 500 Milligramm.
Und dann nehme ich viermal am Tag eins bis zwei Tabletten.
Das ist so viel Label, aber wir können das nicht revisieren.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmeißkala von 1 bis 10,
wenn es 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr stark sind?
Ich würde sagen sieben.
Sind die Schmerzen im Lauferzeit verschlimmert oder verbessert?
Ich würde sagen etwa immer gleich.
Alle gleich?
Die ganze Zeit etwa eine gleiche Intensität.
Immer sein sieben.
Wie betätigt?
Sie haben schon erklärt, die Intensität ist immer sehr stark.
Sieben ist immer sehr stark.
Ungefähr bei sieben, ja.
Mehr oder weniger, aber durchschnittlich für sieben.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder geht manchmal weg?
Nein, das ist dauerhaft.
Haben Sie dagegen aus der Medikamente einnehmen?
Ich habe etwas gemacht.
Ich habe eine Kühlung oder...
Ich habe eine Wärme gemacht.
Manchmal habe ich eine Linderung gemacht, nicht die ganze Zeit.
Also ein bisschen gelendert.
Wärme ist gelendert.
Durch die Wärme hat sich das gelendert.
Haben Sie Schwelligkeit, haben Sie Tarfheizgefühl
oder amaisenlaufen, Krippen im betroffenen Bereich?
Also, meinen rechten Daumen habe ich schon ein bisschen
komisches Tarfheizgefühl und nur Tarfheizgefühl gemacht.
Rechten Daumen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schmerzen am anderen Körperteil?
Ich meine Kopfschmerzen oder Landen-Beschmerzen.
Haben Sie früher ähnliche Becherwärme gehabt?
Nein, das ist erstmalig.
Man hat immer mal so ein bisschen Beschwerden,
aber nicht so.
Das ist, weil ich es zum ersten Mal gehabt habe.
Man schläft ein bisschen falsch und dann am anderen.
Ich habe es immer noch nicht gemacht.
Möchten Sie, gibt es etwas anderer Beschwerden in der Zusammenhang?
Möchten Sie etwas in Zufügen?
Nein, weiß ich nicht, was ich noch dazu fügen soll.
Kopfschmerzen?
Gibt es wichtige Vorerkrankungen in Ihrer Krankengeschichte?
Ich meine, wie Bluthochdruck, Suckerkrankheit,
wie Schmerzen, Schmerzen, Schmerzen,
wie Schmerzen, Schmerzen,
eine der Hautwärme, finns in Ihre Krankengeschichte.
Ich nehme Medikamente gegen meine Cholesterin ein.
Seit zwei Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
20 Milligramm.
20 Milligramm, morgens oder abends oder...
abends.
Okay, gibt es andere Vorerkrankungen?
Also nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Gibt es keine noch mehr, ja?
Also Gott sei Dank nicht, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Ja, okay, das ist gut.
Sind Sie vollstatt geimpft gegen Corona und Kinderkrankheiten?
Kinderkrankheiten schon, aber Corona bin ich nicht geimpft.
Nein, ich habe die Erkrankung durchgemacht und ich wollte keine Weiterimpfung machen.
Okay, und wo hat sich schon einmal operiert?
Ja, in meiner Jugend, da war ich 15 Jahre alt, dann wurde ich an Blindam operiert.
War es Konflikation aus?
Ja, es war keine Konflikation gewesen.
Gibt es noch eine Operation geschüchter?
Nicht, dass ich mich... Nein, es gibt es nicht.
Okay.
Und lieben Ihre Eltern noch, Herr Pischer?
Ja, meine Eltern leben noch.
Gott sei Dank.
Und leidet Ihr Vater irgendeine Grundstöckerkrankung?
Also, wenn Sie sagen, ja, wegen...
Der hat eine Bluthochducherkrankung.
Wie alt ist der?
Der ist 79 Jahre alt.
Und gibt es noch eine andere Erkrankung?
Der hatte mal irgendeine Herzerkrankung, aber ich weiß nicht was.
Aber ich weiß, dass ich eine solche Medikamente bezüglich des Herzens hatte,
aber auch einen Stand bekommen gehabt vor zehn Jahren.
Vor zehn Jahren, danke.
Ein Stand.
Und leidet Ihre Mutter irgendeine Unterkrankung?
Welcher Erkrankung? Ja.
Die nimmt auch, wie ich, Kolesterinsenker, also Medikament bezüglich des Kolesterins ein.
Und die ist übergewichtig und nimmt Medikamente ein wegen Zuckererkrankung.
Zuckererkrankung. Wie alt ist sie?
Sie ist 74.
Sind Sie einsetient, oder haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, so war ich raus, nimmt er keine Medikamente ein.
Der ist jünger als ich.
Okay, das ist gut so, danke.
Wie fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Haben Sie es nicht schon einmal gemessen in der U-Tour Camp?
Ob ich fieberig bin, nein.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich habe auch keinen Fieber.
Ich fühle mich nicht so, dass ich Fieber haben würde.
Haben Sie Schöpfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Wie bitte?
Haben Sie Schöpfrost, leiden Sie unter?
Nach 20 Minuten? Nein.
Schlafen Sie danach gut?
Normalerweise schon, aber durch die Schmerzen wache ich ein paar Mal auf.
Ich warte unbedingt.
Wie ist die Appetit?
Normalerweise gut.
Haben Sie in der Stallzeit Märkli ab oder zu genommen?
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter Schwierigkeiten beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Durchfall, Verstoffung? Nein.
Oder Belehungen?
Wie ist die Stress beim Privatleben oder bei der Arbeit?
Nicht so besonders.
Wir sind immer stressig.
Wenn man Taxi fährt, wenn Sie Auto fahren,
gibt es immer irgendwelche komische Autofahrer,
die schnell oder langsam fahren.
Aber sonst habe ich keinen Stress.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wenn Sie haben Recht.
Aber Sie haben eine Medikamente genommen.
Sie haben es auch gemacht?
Die Novalgien, die ich von meinen Eltern bekommen habe.
Meine Mutter hat mir eine Novalgien gegeben.
Es hat mir ein bisschen hilft, aber nicht wirklich.
Ich habe schon Schmerzen.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie eine Fische? Nein, ich brauche sie nicht.
Haben Sie schon einmal probiert?
Ich habe es schon einmal probiert, aber ich habe nicht gebraucht.
Ich habe nicht gebraucht.
Einmal probiert, aber ich habe es nur probiert.
Sie sind ein paar Jahre her.
Wie lange?
Ich habe schon über 30 Jahre her.
Ich habe in meiner Jugend versucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, bei Gelegenheit.
Wenn es ein Feier ist,
dann ist es ein Geburtstagfeier.
Aber nicht regelmäßig.
Trinken Sie?
Ich trinke sie nie.
Ich trinke nicht regelmäßig Alkohol.
Aber was trinken Sie?
Was dort weiter Geburtstagfeier ist.
Manchmal Bier, manchmal Whisky.
Wie viel Menge trinken Sie?
Ein Glas, ein Flasche, ein Dose.
Ein zwei Flaschen ist mindestens Bierflasche.
Aber es ist nicht jede Woche ein Feier.
Ich verstehe kein Problem.
Haben Sie einmal Druck probiert?
Nein.
Sind Sie aller Alkohol gegen etwas?
Gegen Nüsse und Gräser.
Ich habe es nicht.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Durch jucken in meinem Auge,
jucken und brennen und Nase laufen.
Jucken, Auge, laufende Nase.
Wie eine Konjunktur.
Gibt es andere?
Ich habe es nicht.
Wie reagieren Sie?
Geben Sie beide Alargen.
Was reagieren Sie?
Ich habe es nicht.
Es ist egal, ob es Nüsse oder Gräser sind.
Es ist gleich.
Und Verträgtel, ne, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay.
Sie haben sehr gut erklärt, haben Sie schon einmal verletzt?
Ich muss mich auch fragen.
Wie?
Ob ich eine Verletzung hatte?
Ja, haben Sie verletzt?
Ja.
Was meinen Sie mit Verletzungen?
Ich meine, aufgestoßen.
Wie?
Aufgestoßen.
Aufgestoßen, was meinen Sie da?
Angeschlagen.
Das ist nur mein, ob ich gestürzt und verletzt bin.
Ja, ich meine das.
Ja, ich habe mich bestimmt geprältig.
Ich habe früher Fußball gespielt, da hat man sich verletzt.
Dann bin ich Fahrrad gefahren, wo ich umklar bin.
Seit einer Woche.
Seit einer Woche lang.
Also in der einen Woche?
Nee.
Also in der letzten Woche?
Ich hatte nur vorher meinen Freund geholfen beim Umzug geholfen und da hatte ich Pakete
getragen und Schrank getragen und so weiter.
Aber ich bin nicht gestürzt.
Okay.
Hab es sich Schwellung bemerkt im betroffenen Bereich?
Schwellung?
Nein.
Gibt es offene Bünde?
Offene Bünde habe ich auch nicht gesehen.
Okay.
Gibt es Hauptfolbänderungen beim betroffenen Bereich?
Hauptfolbende?
Nein.
Okay.
Sie beiden, ob das rot oder blau oder so, was ist dein?
Ich denke, alle wichtige Fragen schon gestalten.
Herr Fischer, so als wäre die Sikreferale Unterversuchung, danach wäre die Abwuld abnehmen.
Und bisgebernde paar Paaren sprechen wir über ihre Festen.
Also, die Sikreferale, die ich unterseh, dann werde ich untersuchen.
Und dann werde ich untersuchen.
Und dann werde ich Bildgebände, Paaren durchführen.
Was meint ihr, was meint ihr mit Bildgebänden, Frau Frahn?
Röntgen.
Und besonders, wenn Röntgen, beide Röntgen, unser eigener Ergebnis ist, oder befunden, ist genug uns.
Oder wenn wir mehr brauchen, mehr Untersuchungen brauchen, werde ich auch MRT durchführen.
Okay.
Durchführen?
Machen Sie das?
Veranlassen.
Ah, okay.
Um weit Gewebe, weit Gewebe zu beurteilen.
Was zu beurteilen, Mahmau?
Weit Gewebe beurteilen.
Weit Gewebe.
Weich Gewebe.
Weich Gewebe beurteilen.
Okay.
Dankeschön.
Mitnehmen Sie das Platz.
Haben die Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe noch andere Fragen.
Bitte schön.
2 Fragen, bitte.
Traiben Sie Sport?
Regelmäßig?
Regelmäßig, ja.
Ich fahre öfters Fahrrad.
Nicht regelmäßig, aber man kann schon sagen, regelmäßig.
Wie lange pro Tag fahren Sie Fahrrad?
Ich fahre nicht pro Tag.
2 oder 3 Mal die Woche fahre ich 20 Kilometer.
Also pro Tag, pro Strecke.
Seid man fahren Sie der Fahrrad?
Ja, schon seit 10 Jahren.
Danke schön.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie Kraftverlust in Ihre rechte Arm oder linke Arm?
Kraftverlust? Nee, habe ich nicht.
Die 2. Frage ist, haben Sie Schmerzen bei Bewegung?
Ja, Schmerz-Zunahme bei Bewegung meinen Sie.
Wenn ich meinen Kopf nach rechts drehe,
kann ich dich ganz nach rechts drehen, weil es Schmerz-Zunimmt.
Danke für die Antwort.
Noch eine Frage, Kollegen.
Ich habe eine Frage für die Differenz der Diagnose.
Unsere Kollegen haben gefragt, bei Bewegung, aber sie haben gesagt,
dass es sehr Bewegung ist.
Ja, das hat der Schmerzen vielleicht gesagt.
Bei Beleustern laufen, fahren, haben Sie Schmerzen?
Auch Zuladen? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstolpern oder Luftnoten?
Luftnoten, so, nee, habe ich nicht.
Okay, das war meine Frage.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen, aber auch keine Atemabhängigen.
Weil der Patient hat die Zimastätin eingenommen,
deswegen gibt es eine eine Erste-Karantäne,
deswegen für die Differenz der Diagnose müssen wir fragen.
Ich habe noch eine Frage für die Kollegen.
Ich habe eine Frage für die Frau.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt, ich habe einen Moment.
Ich habe 9 Patienten vorstellt.
Ja, wirklich, sie ist nicht los.
Okay.
Paul Fischer ist 49 Jahre alt, jahre Jahre Patient.
Er ist 21 kg, 75 kg groß.
Er hat sich heute bei uns,
wegen einer Erwohne,
in den Zwischenstücken beendet.
Die Zwischenstücke ist für mich ganz wichtig.
hat der Psyvikal Schmerzen vorgestellt.
Passiant berichtete, dass die Schmerzen nach der Umzug
nach der Umzug, Umzug geholfen, abgetreten.
Auf, Auftrag, oder, dass die Schmerzen
nachgeworfen, umzugauftrag sozusagen oder begonnen hatte.
Ja.
Okay.
Und die Schmerzen würden
bis rechte Schulter,
ausstrahlen, rechte Schulterblatt ausstrahlen.
Ausstrahlen.
Dagegen habe er normal gehen Tablet 534 Milligramm viermal am Tag
eingenommen.
Auf der Schmerzköhle legen die Schmerzen bei der Intensität von
von 7.
7 von 10.
7 von wie viel.
Ich würde die das ein bisschen genauer sagen.
Also 7 von 10.
Okay.
Die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen verschlimmerten
sich beim Kopfbewegung.
Was für eine Art für Bewegung?
Der Drehen.
Rotation.
Wie?
Ja, genau.
Bei der, welche Richtung?
Rechts.
Rechts Seite.
Rechts Rotation, genau.
Die Schmerzzunahme war,
die Schmerzunahme ist bei Restrotation zunehmend.
Ja.
Ein.
Mit einer Zunehmend.
Okay.
Zunehmend, ja.
Ja.
Der Patient, ja.
Der Patient gab an,
gab an am rechten,
am rechten Daumen,
Daumen,
Parisie zu haben.
Ja.
Parisie zu haben, ja, genau.
Parisie.
Und diese Beschwerden seien eismalig.
Zum Linderung.
Eismalig aufgetreten.
Aufgetreten.
Der Rüber fügte er hinzu,
dass er
mit warmen Kompressionen
die Schmerzengeländerat
mit, mit Wärmebehandlung.
Die Kompression, die Kompression ist ja ein Druck.
Okay.
Mit, mit Wärmebehandlung.
Die Fragen,
die Fragen,
die Erregung,
die Vor shower esstol und Kraftverlust,
wurden verneint.
Okay.
Und repräsentieren.
Seit 2 Jahren an die Repariv Sammy,
der reactions
ę.
Er wurde bei ihm eine Pandektomie durchgeführt.
In der Familie Nanamnestich leide sein Vater mit neun und sechstisch Jahren an Art...
79.
79 Jahren an Art.
Art.
Er hatte auch Probleme vor zehn Jahren.
Er wurde bei ihm ein Stand...
Was ist das?
Ein Stand...
Ein gelegt?
Implantiert.
Seine Mutter leide mit 64 Jahren an Art.
74?
Ja, 70, 70.
Vielleicht spreche ich schon ein bisschen hessisch.
70, 60, 70, 80.
Weiter?
Leider an Holästil-Hyperlipidemie und Diabetes mellitus 2 und Adiposität.
Sein Bruder sei gesund.
Die Vegetative Nanamnese war unabhängig bis auf Schmerzbedingte Dissemene.
Schmerzbedingte?
Nein, ich habe das Akustisch gehört, was ich gesagt habe.
Im Satz komplett, bitte nochmal sagen.
Die Vegetative Nanamnese war unabhängig bis auf Schmerzbedingte Dissemene.
Ich habe das nicht gesagt, aber das geschmeckt nicht.
Er hat in der Schule einmal Rahn probiert, aber das geschmeckt nicht.
Er hat nie gedacht.
Er hat immer gelegant, besonders am Feiern, ein oder zwei Flasche Bier oder Wein.
Die Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er hat keine Unverträglichkeiten.
Mein Verdacht Diagnose ist das Risiko zu Prolaubs beim Servikalbereich.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen Luxation.
Was meinen Sie mit Luxation?
Schulter Luxation.
Reisseitige Schulter Luxation.
Ist da ein Trauma bekannt?
Nein, ich habe keine Trauma.
Kann man trotzdem eine Schulter Luxation haben?
Nein, Schulter Luxation kann man trotzdem haben.
Wenn man kein Trauma hat, kann man trotzdem eine Schulter Luxation haben.
Das ist eine Frage an Sie.
Es gibt auch die habituelle Luxation.
Was könnte es noch sein?
Einfach fragtourische Reisütsch.
Eine pathologische Fraktur.
Könnte sein, der Potenzialdiagnose.
Was könnte noch sein?
Im Betracht.
Einfach eine andere Erkrankung.
Wie Spondylolisthese.
Man kann auch Blockade von Facettengelenkungen haben.
Wie würden Sie vorangehen?
Ich werde die Patienten körperlich und neurologisch untersuchen.
Ich kontrolliere die Biotheile.
Ich kontrolliere die motorische und reflektische Kraft.
Und die muskaleinigen Reflexe.
Sie haben einen Verdachtdiagnose, das ein Bandscheimverfall hat.
Nachdem Sie untersucht haben, würden Sie noch irgendwelche Bildgebende Maßnahmen durchführen?
Ich wollte Torax bei zwei Ebenen.
Warum Torax?
Weil das ist obere Extremität.
Sie haben Probleme im Nacken.
Wie würden Sie das Röntgen anmelden?
Im Zwei Ebenen.
Und MRT.
Schritt für Schritt.
Wenn dieser Befunder nicht genug ist.
Warum würden Sie ein CT oder MRT nehmen?
Weil beim Röntgen kann man nur Knochen und Hartgewebe beurteilen.
Wie möchten Sie auch Nerven, Muskeln oder Legen beurteilen?
Was Sie CT gesagt haben?
Wenn Sie einen CT machen, kann man das machen.
CT ist billiger als MRT.
Wenn jemand eine Kontraintekration hat, wenn er eine Klausophobie hat, kann man lieber ein CT machen.
Dann kann man auch einen CT machen.
Nehmen wir mal an, ein MRT wurde gemacht.
Sie haben auch ihre Verdachtdiagnose erhärtet.
Dieser Patient, der Fischer, hat einen Wandschein vorfall.
Er hat eine Schmerz, die er nicht empfehlen kann.
Er hat eine Bewegungsschulung.
Er hat eine Schmerz, die er nicht empfiehlt.
Er hat Schmerzen.
Was würden Sie als erstes eine Schmerztherapie regieren?
Welches Medikament ist das Wichtige?
Ein Medikament, das würden Sie geben.
Dann kann man noch zusätzlich noch andere Mittel geben.
Zusätzlich zu der Schmerztherapie, kann man Bewegung machen.
Man kann zusätzlich weitere Schmerzinfusionen geben.
Man kann auch weitere Schmerzinfusionen geben.
Wenn die konservative Therapie mit dem Muskelentspandel mitgehen,
können Sie geben Muskelrelaxanz.
Falls die konservative Therapie nicht ausreicht?
Man kann auch eine operative Therapie diskutieren.
Man kann in der Orthopädie versuchen, konservativ Therapie zu empfehlen.
Weil der Patient keine Müskel-Lebung hat, ist das nicht als erste Indikation eine OP,
sondern erst die konservative Therapie.
Wenn es nicht geht, dann die operative Wasdarm eventuell.
Herr Kollege, wir haben eine Anfrage von Ihnen.
Wir würden Sie mit Ihren eigenen Worten die Hauptbeschwerden des Patienten vorstellen.
Wie? Noch mal?
Wie würden Sie mit Ihren eigenen Worten vorstellen?
Das ist jetzt aber nicht eine leere Stunde, weil ich nicht weiß, was Sie in den Kursen oder Prüfungen bekommen.
Wenn ich in der Klinik wäre, würde ich dem Herrn Oberarzt vorstellen.
Herr Waatz, ich habe einen Patienten aufgenommen, der ist 49 Jahre alt.
Er hat seit einer Woche cervicale Schmerzen, die in den rechten Schulterblatt ziehen.
Er gibt in den rechten Daumen eine Parise an, aber hat keine Parisen.
Er hat bewegungsabregende Schmerzen, insbesondere bei Rechtsrotation der Halsfürbesäule.
Er nehme bezüglich den Schmerzen Novalgien ein.
Er hat 4-mal am Tag 1-2 Tabletten zur Schmerzlinderung.
Zusätzlich würde er eine Schmerzlinderung für Wärmebehandlungen machen.
Er hat eine Schmerzlinderung, dadurch hat er auch eine Schmerzlinderung.
Ich glaube, das war es.
Meine vertersche Diagnose ist Cervicotoracalgirechts.
Meine differenzialdiagnose wäre Cervical-Bandscheim-Vorfall oder eine Cervical-Spondylylistese,
oder eine Facettengelenksyndrom, um diese Therapie zu erhärtern oder eine Faktur auszuschließen.
Wenn ich eine Röntgenuntersuchung der Halsfürbesäule in zwei Ebenen durchführen lassen würde,
und wenn ich dort keine Informationen gewinnen würde, würde ich das noch ergänzen mit einem MRT der Halsfürbesäule.
Damit kann man auch Weichteilgewebe besser beurteilen, wie zum Beispiel die Bandscheiben.
Da auch eine Spinalkanaleinigung gibt und so weiter.
Da der Patient nicht eine Paräse hat, keine Muskelspächer hat, würde ich eine konservative Therapie einladen mit analgesie,
beginnend mit NSR, zusätzlich vielleicht Norvaldien, zusätzlich noch Samal oder Thylidin.
Muskelentschwande Medikamente würde ich eben einleiten, Physiotherapie würde ich einleiten.
Wenn unter dieser Maßnahme das nicht besser wird, spätestens dann, wenn das MRT nicht durchgeführt wäre,
dann würde ich ein MRT durchführen lassen, spätestens dann, und dann würde ich dann mit den Patienten diskutieren,
wie wir weiter vangehen, ob man eine operative Therapie empfehlen würde.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Kollege, unsere Kollege gab zwei Reaktionen ab.
Einmal Reaktionen, sind sie verheiratet? Sie haben gesagt, ich bin geschieden.
Unsere Kollegin hat gesagt, es tut mir leid.
Das sagt man normalerweise nicht, weil ich bin Gott sei Dank geschieden, kann ich auch sagen.
Und zweite Reaktion ist, unsere Kollegin hat gefragt,
Leben ich der Eltern noch, sie haben gesagt, Gott sei Dank.
Sind diese Reaktionen angemessen oder nicht, Herr Scham?
Also normalerweise interessiert es dem Patienten nicht, ob die noch leben oder nicht.
Also eigentlich unwichtig, ob die leben oder nicht.
Man muss nicht zusätzlich sagen, Gott sei Dank, dass sie noch leben.
Vielleicht ist es nicht Gott sei Dank, vielleicht sind die Eltern.
Sie haben gesagt, ich habe keine Zigarette geraucht.
Ich würde nicht unbedingt darauf beziehen, ob ich überhaupt einen,
wenn einmal oder zweimal oder zehnmal in einem Leben, ich bin 49 Jahre alt,
in diesem Person, ob ich da jetzt eine Woche oder eine geraucht habe.
Ich denke, medizinisch gesehen, das macht keine Relevante,
ob ich jetzt eine Woche geraucht habe.
Deswegen kann man sagen, er ist nicht geraucht.
Aber wenn ich mal eine Zeit lang geraucht habe, also nicht versucht habe,
ich habe gesagt, ich habe versucht.
Also das heißt, wenn man noch genauer nimmt, wenn ich noch nicht mal inhaliert habe,
wenn ich nur gepaft habe, man kann ja auch paffen, so rauchen,
dann hat man ja nicht null, nur mal null geraucht sozusagen.
Dann ist man passiv rauf, aber vielleicht schlimmer.
Haben sie passiv geraucht, kann man sagen, waren sie mit vielen Leuten.
Ich würde da nicht so genau da hingehen.
Wenn einer sagt, er hat es nicht geraucht, dann hat er nicht geraucht.
Wenn er gesagt hat, ich habe in meiner Jugend einmal kurz probiert,
dann kann man, denke ich, nach meiner Meinung direkt sagen, er ist nicht raucher.
Danke schön, das war meine Frage.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen, als als Gescheppe für die als als Gescheppe?
Kann ich eine Frage stellen?
Bitte schön.
Wenn der Patient sagt, dass zum Beispiel ich trinke nur belegentlich Alkohol,
muss er mir ausführlich fragen, ob trinken Sie und so weiter?
Ja, es kommt auch an, wie er das gelegentlich meint.
Da kann man schon fragen, was meinen Sie mit gelegentlich?
Zum Beispiel, wenn einer jede Woche Ende ein Party geht,
oder zu einer Feier geht, dann ist es ja jede Woche regelmäßig.
Man kann schon fragen, aber gelegentlich heißt dann,
bei dem Alkohol ist gelegentlich relativ, sozusagen.
Theoretisch kann man schon fragen, wie viel man da trinkt,
also bei einer Feier, theoretisch kann man fragen,
aber ich denke mal, ein Nichtregel,
also nicht alle Alkohol oder der nicht regelmäßig Alkohol trinkt,
dann ist es unterschiedlich. Je nach Feier, da kann sein,
dass da gut drauf ist, und dann trinkt er vielleicht zwei Fleischbeer,
vier Fleischbeer, und der andere Feier trinkt da nur eine Fleischbeer,
oder so, weil es nicht so schöne Feier ist.
Weiß ich nicht. Kann man fragen, aber Ihre Frage war,
sollte man fragen, gelegentlich ist relativ.
Kann man ja mit ein, zwei Fragen, nicht zu viel fragen,
aber mit ein, zwei Fragen kann man ein bisschen detaillierter aushören,
ob das jetzt viel ist, was meinen Sie mit gelegentlich?
Kann man sagen, die Fragestellung wäre von mir,
was meinen Sie mit gelegentlich, ist es gelegentlich jede Wochenende
oder gelegentlich alle paar Wochen oder alle paar Monate,
dann ist es gelegentlich für mich.
Okay, danke so.
Wir haben eine Frage, der Patriot hat gesagt,
eine Woche gleich bleiben diese Schmerzen hat.
Deswegen können wir persistieren, schreiben oder da überhaupt schreiben?
Persistieren.
Persistieren, eigentlich persistieren, seit einer Woche persistieren
die Schmerzen, kann man sagen.
Persistieren, der ist angemessen, aber dauerhafte Schmerzen,
kann man auch sagen, persistierende oder dauerhafte.
Persistierende ist ein bisschen fraglicher.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich glaube, in Deutschland nicht nur Parästhesie verwenden,
sondern auch Krippeln, Parästhesie.
Ja, danke.
Warum?
Um das vielleicht zu betonen, glaube ich.
Das eine ist Fragestellung, das andere ist ja Krippeln.
Parästhesie heißt ja auch, dass es wenig Empfindung ist, zum Beispiel.
Und Krippeln ist, dass es wenig Empfindung und ein bisschen Krippeln,
Armeisen laufen irgendwie noch.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?